Last week,
the congress of deputies
approved the amnesty law.
But when it comes into effect,
could puchimon
to run for election
May 12 Troops?
The congress of deputies
passed the amnesty law
Thanks to the agreement between PSOE and yuns,
after the latest amendments to the text
claimed by the
independentistas to armor Carlos Puchito Moni,
their own,
in the face of cases brought by terrorism,
High treason and embezzlement.
The initiative will now be sent to the Senate
to continue the process there.
In the upper chamber,
the PP has an absolute majority
and use it to delay the process as much as possible,
i.e.,
2 months.
It is then estimated that
that until May
the law does not return to Congress for approval
definitively,
right in the middle of the election campaign.
European elections to be held
June 09.
A puchilamón,
for his part,
nothing prevents you
to run for election as a yunts candidate
and has already headed the lists for the 2,021 elections.
symbolically,
while on the run on the bank.
However,
he would not be able to campaign in Moscow,
as he still has 1 search warrant on him.
But the big question is,
could he be sworn in as President?
The answer is,
it depends,
since in order to be invested President of the yernality
should go to parliament in person
Catalan for the investiture session.
And precisely for that to happen,
amnesty should already be in effect